at Philadelphia International Airport
wheelchairs used to take elderly or
immobile passengers to or from their
planes and gates sit empty and for the
wheelchair attendants many have been
laid off or facing difficult choices
like Reginald Smith a husband and father
forced to choose between possibly
contracting coronavirus at the airport
and bringing it home to his family or
quitting his job knowing it would lead
to financial hardship he chose his
family's health
my wife was high risk with diabetes and
I just had to take a precaution of her I
didn't want to get so had when people
coming all across the world and stuff no
matter who we picking up me get it
didn't turn around with her being
average bring home to the family
a labor union representative says over
600 philadelphia airport workers he
represents from the Service Employees
Union have been laid off they were all
contract employees hired by third party
companies baggage handlers skycaps
wheelchair tennis plane creams folks
providing food and you know they seem to
be leaving them out entirely you know of
the equation and they're the ones who
they airlines are the ones that see
direct all that work at Philadelphia's
Airport passenger traffic has plummeted
from ninety thousand travelers a day to
just a few hundred a day of the 450
daily flights most have been canceled
and of the 165 permanent airport stores
less than ten remain open it's
unprecedented this is different this is
this is going to be challenging for us
to come back from many airport workers
won't be getting their jobs back until
people start flying again and airports
return to how they were before the
corona virus pandemic but some experts
say that could be as long as two years
from now in empty airports devoid of
busy commotion that provide livelihoods
to so many people that used to work
there Gabriel Sandow algae's
Zita Philadelphia